let's see if we can write 21 sixtieths
as a decimal and I'll give you a little
hint see if you can rewrite this as a
fraction with a hundred as the
denominator or another way to see 8
another way to say see if you can
rewrite this so it's a certain number of
hundredths and then you can represent
that as a decimal so we've done this
before we can rewrite a fraction we can
get an equivalent fraction if we either
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by the same quantity or we
divide the numerator and the denominator
by the same quantity and this numerator
and this denominator it looks pretty
clear 21 is divisible by 3 and 7 + 1 +
21 + 60 is clearly divisible by 3 as
well it's not divisible by 7 or 21 well
of course it's divisible by 1 but that
doesn't really help you much so let's
see if we can rewrite this maybe with
lower numbers where we divide both the
numerator and the denominator by that
common factor of 3 so we're dividing by
3 so I'm just rewriting this as an
equivalent fraction that might make it a
little bit easier for our heads to get
around it so 21 divided by 3 is equal to
7 and 60 divided by 3 is equal to 20 so
we've rewritten 21 sixtieths as 7 xx so
you might be saying Sal why did you even
do this did aren't we trying to get it
in terms of hundredths well this was
kind of a this one helps simplify it in
my brain a little bit and what's extra
good about writing it is 720 it's is
that it's much it's easy to go from 20
to 100 to go from 20 to 100 we just have
to multiply by 5 well if each section is
going to be 5 times as many then these 7
sections are going to be five times as
many so once again we're multiplying the
numerator and the denominator by the
same thing and so this is going to be
equal to 35 over 100 or 35 hundredths 35
we write it a little bit 35 hundredths
which is what we wanted to do we wanted
to rewrite this in terms of hundredths
and what is 35 hundredths well let's
just remind ourselves when we're writing
a decimal that's the ones place that's
the ones place
this right over here this next place is
the tenths place
that's the tenths place and the next
place is the hundreds place is the
hundreds hundreds place and so 35
hundredths well you could write that
like this you could write that as 35
hundredths so you could literally write
this as 0.35 and you might say wait wait
you put a three in the tens place why is
this 35 hundreds I get that this is five
hundreds but why is this 35 hundredths
well three tenths is 30 hundredths so
this is thirty-five hundred so another
way of thinking about it you could
rewrite this right over here you could
rewrite this as being equal to 30 30
over 100 30 over 100 plus five over 100
plus five over 100 and well how can and
what is 30 over 100 if you wanted to
rewrite it in terms of tenths well you
could just divide the numerator and the
denominator by 10 divided by 10 and you
would get three tenths three tenths plus
5/100 plus 5/100 and we see that right
over here three tenths
that's the tens place plus 5/100 so
that's the hundreds place or this is
sometimes referred to as 35 hundredths
35 hundredths